>>> HE'S GOT BDE, EVERYBODY KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS?
>> CALL IT BIG DeSANTIS ENERGY.
HE'S GOT THE SAME KIND OF BDE
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS.
>> WELL, IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
BDE ACTUALLY STANDS FOR, FEEL
FREE TO GOOGLE IT.
THAT WAS KARI LAKE ENERGIZING
MAGA REPUBLICANS IN THEIR FIRST
BIG RALLY SINCE THE FBI SEARCH
ON FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
FLORIDA HOME.
AS SHE AND RON DeSANTIS ARE
AIMING TO REBRAND THE GRAND OLD
PARTY.
KYUNG LAH IS IN ARIZONA TO FIND
OUT IF THE RAMBUNCTIOUS LANGUAGE
WILL SWAY OR ALIENATE VOTERS.
>> EAST MEETS WEST.
IN A SHOW OF A UNITED REPUBLICAN
FRONT.
THE HEADLINER OF THIS ARIZONA
RALLY, FLORIDA GOVERNOR AND
POSSIBLE 2024 HOPEFUL, RON
DeSANTIS.
>> FROM THE BEACHES OF FLORIDA
TO THE DESERTS OF ARIZONA,
NOVEMBER 8th, 2022, IS GOING TO
BE THE DAY THAT AMERICA FIGHTS
BACK.
>> TO ENERGIZE THIS PHOENIX
CROWD, DeSANTIS TURNED HIS
POLITICAL FIRE TO THE NEWS IN
HIS STATE.
THE FBI SEARCH OF DONALD TRUMP'S
MAR-A-LAGO ESTATE.
>> THEY'RE ENFORCING THE LAW
BASED ON WHO THEY LIKE AND WHO
THEY DON'T LIKE.
THAT IS NOT A REPUBLIC.
MAYBE IT'S A BANANA REPUBLIC
WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
>> ECHOED BY KARI LAKE, HEAVY ON
GRIEVANCE, LIGHT ON FACTS.
>> THEN THESE PEOPLE SENT
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED FEDERAL
AGENTS TO PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP'S HOME AND RAIDED IT.
HOW DARE THEY.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST LARGE
POLITICAL RALLY SINCE THE
MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH.
>> HOW MUCH IS THAT AFFECTING
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE GOING TO BE
VOTING THIS YEAR IN THE
MIDTERMS?
>> I HOPE IT'S A LOT.
I HOPE IT IGNITES PEOPLE, GETS
THEM OUT THERE, AND THEY WANT TO
HELP SUPPORT THE REPUBLICAN
TICKET.
>> AFTER WHAT HAPPENED ON
MONDAY, WE HAVE TO SHOW OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE PRESIDENT.
THE REAL PRESIDENT, ANYWAY.
>> HERE IN ARIZONA, WHERE
TRUMP'S 2020 ELECTION LIE STILL
THRIVES IN A BIG SWATH OF THE
GOP, HIS ENDORSED CANDIDATE
SWEPT IN THE STATE'S PRIMARY.
>> KARI LAKE DEFEATED A
REPUBLICAN BACKED BY MIKE PENCE
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT.
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY ISN'T
YOUR GREAT, GREAT GRANDFATHER'S
PARTY ANYMORE.
>> U.S. SENATE CANDIDATE BLAKE
MASTERS IS ALSO TRUMP ENDORSED.
>> IT WILL BE ARIZONA FIRST AND
AMERICA FIRST ALL THE WAY.
>> THE PROOF IS IN THE
PRIMARIES, SAY VOTERS IN THIS
CROWD, THAT THE MORE CENTRIST
ARIZONA REPUBLICAN PARTY OF JOHN
McCAIN IS GONE.
>> WE FEEL McCAIN IS A TOTAL
TRAITOR.
I BELIEVE HE WAS A RINO.
>> IN THIS THEATER, PARTY UNITY
AND ITS SUCCESS IN NOVEMBER IS
UNDER THE BANNER OF TRUMP.
I SPOKE WITH A DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE FOR GOVERNOR HERE IN THE
STATE OF ARIZONA, KATIE HOBBS,
AND SHE DISAGREES WITH THIS
PHILOSOPHY OF RUNNING TO TRUMP
IN NOVEMBER AS THE TICKET TO
WIN.
ONE-THIRD OF REGISTERED VOTERS
IN THE STATE ARE INDEPENDENTS.
AND HOBBS BELIEVES BY CATERING
TO THEM, TALKING TO THEM
DIRECTLY, IS A WAY TO WIN IN
THIS BATTLEGROUND STATE.
JAKE.
>> ALL RIGHT, KYUNG LAH, THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL, AND
LET ME START WITH YOU.
IF ARIZONA'S ELECTION DENYING
REPUBLICAN GUBERNATORIAL
CANDIDATE KARI LAKE AND
REPUBLICAN SECRETARY OF STATE
CANDIDATE, IF THEY HAD HELD
OFFICE IN 2020, THEY SAY THEY
WOULD HAVE DECERTIFIED THE
RESULTS AND OVERTURNED THE
ELECTION IN FAVOR OF TRUMP, EVEN
THOUGH THAT'S NOT HOW THE VOTERS
OF ARIZONA VOTING.
ACCORDING TO A "WASHINGTON POST"
ANALYSIS, QUOTE, ACROSS THE
BATTLEGROUND STATES THAT DECIDE
THE 2020 VOTE, CANDIDATES WHO
DENY THE LEGITIMACY OF THAT
ELECTION HAVE CLAIMED NEARLY
TWO-THIRDS OF GOP NOMINATIONS
FOR STATE AND FEDERAL OFFICES
WITH AUTHORITY OVER ELECTIONS.
YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN WHO SUPPORTS
DEMOCRACY AND ELECTION RESULTS.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THIS?
>> THIS HAS ALWAYS BEEN THE
BIGGEST THREAT.
WE TALK ABOUT THE VOTING LAWS IN
GEORGIA AND TEXAS.
THIS IS ALWAYS A THREAT.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTUALLY IN
CHARGE WHO HAVE TO SIGN OFF ON
ELECTIONS ARE ELECTION DENIERS.
YOU'RE IN A SITUATION HERE WHERE
YOU WOULD THINK THAT IN A
GENERAL ELECTION, MAYBE YOU
WOULD TEMPER SOME OF THIS.
MAYBE YOU ARE JUST TRYING TO GET
THROUGH A PRIMARY.
BUT CLEARLY THESE PEOPLE TRULY
BELIEVE THIS STUFF.
THAT'S WHAT'S SCARY ABOUT IT.
>> SOME OF THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN ACCUSED OF PLAYING WITH
FIRE BY SUPPORTING THESE MORE
EXTREMIST REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
HOPING THAT WILL GIVE THEM A LEG
UP.
WE SAW THAT PLAY OUT IN MICHIGAN
WITH CONGRESSMAN PETER MAIER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
CAN THE DEMOCRATS SAY THIS IS AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO THE
COUNTRY BUT WE'RE GOING TO PLAY
CUTE BY HELPING TO NOMINATE SOME
OF THESE ELECTION DENYING
REPUBLICANS.
>> I THINK IT'S QUITE DANGEROUS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST WHAT
HAPPENS IN 2022.
THEY'RE LAYING THE FOUNDATION
FOR THE NEXT PRESIDENT ELECTION
IN '24 BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE, IF
THEY WIN, THEY WILL BE THE ONES
TO DECIDE WHETHER TO CERTIFY THE
NEXT ELECTION.
WE'RE IN AN EXISTENTIAL CRISIS.
WE CANNOT ALLOW PEOPLE WHO WILL
BREAK THE LAW, WHO WILL LIE, WHO
BELIEVE THE BIG LIE, TO BE
ELECTED.
I DON'T THINK -- I THINK
DEMOCRATS COULD WIN EVEN IF THEY
HAD MODERATES THAT THEY WERE
RUNNING AGAINST IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> FRANCESCA, "THE WASHINGTON
POST" IS REPORTING A GROUP OF
LAWYERS ALIGNED WITH TRUMP LED A
TEAM OF COMPUTER EXPERTS TO
OBTAIN DATA FROM ELECTION
SOFTWARE AS PART OF A BROAD
ORGANIZED MULTISTATE EFFORT
AFTER THE 2020 ELECTION.
YOU COVER TRUMP.
ARE YOU SURPRISED BY HOW WELL
ORGANIZED SOME OF THIS WAS?
>> WE KNOW THAT AFTER THE
ELECTION THAT THEY WERE IN MANY
OF THESE STATES TRYING TO DO
WHAT "THE WASHINGTON POST"
DESCRIBED THERE.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
GET IN THEIR OWN PEOPLE IN SOME
OF THESE STATES FOLLOWING THE
ELECTION BECAUSE THEY DO THINK
THEY COULD BE DECIDED AT THAT
LEVEL IN THE 2024 ELECTION.
AND THIS IS WHY THOSE GROUPS
HAVE BEEN SO FOCUSED ON GETTING
AN REPUBLICAN ATTORNEY GENERAL
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE IT TO
THE COURTS AFTER THE ELECTION IF
NOT JUST IN 2022, BUT IN 2024,
POTENTIALLY ALSO, IF THEY DON'T
GET THE RESULT THEY WANT.
>> KASIE, YOU WERE IN WYOMING A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
I WAS THERE LAST WEEK, ALTHOUGH
FOR FUN.
NOT FOR WORK.
>> I'M JEALOUS OF YOUR TRIP.
>> BUT LIZ CHENEY OBVIOUSLY IS
RUNNING FOR RE-ELECTION AND
FACING A VERY STRONG CHALLENGE
FOR A REPUBLICAN, A UNIVERSITY
OF WYOMING POLL FOUND CHENEY
TRAILING BY NEARLY 30 POINTS
LAST WEEK, 30 POINTS.
CNN HAS REPORTED CHENEY'S
OBVIOUSLY LOOKING AHEAD TO 2024,
POTENTIALLY.
IS THERE ENOUGH APPETITE, DO YOU
THINK, FOR AN ANTI-TRUMP
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE?
MORE SO PERHAPS THAN ONE IN
WYOMING FOR CONGRESS?
>> I THINK IT'S A REALLY TRICKY
PATH FORWARD FOR LIZ CHENEY.
I THINK THEY'RE VERY AWARE SHE'S
UNLIKELY TO WIN NEXT TUESDAY.
BUT I THINK THAT THEY'RE
BASICALLY -- I MEAN, I THINK SHE
DEEPLY BELIEVES THAT IT IS
ACTUALLY WORTH WHAT HAS
HAPPENED.
IT'S WORTH LOSING HER SEAT, AND
THAT IS WHAT MAKES HER DIFFERENT
FROM SO MANY OTHER REPUBLICANS
IN THE TRUMP ERA, WHO JUST WERE
NOT WILLING TO POTENTIALLY GIVE
UP THEIR OWN POWER IN SERVICE TO
A GREATER GOOD BEING THE COUNTRY
AND DEMOCRACY, AND I THINK SHE'S
REALLY TAKING A STAND ON THAT.
WHEN I WAS OUT THERE, I HEARD
HER TALK TO VOTERS ABOUT IT.
IT WASN'T JUST IN INTERVIEWS
WITH THE NATIONAL MEDIA.
IT'S WHAT SHE WAS SAYING TO
CONSTITUENTS ON THE GROUND.
IT'S A TOUGH PATH FORWARD.
I THINK EVERYONE AT THIS TABLE
KNOWS, RUNNING IN THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY ON A LIZ CHENEY PLATFORM
IS A TOUGH SELL.
>> ON THAT SUBJECT, I THINK
THERE WERE A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
WHO DIDN'T SUPPORT TRUMP BUT
WERE HOPEFUL THEY COULD HAVE THE
TRUMP POLICIES IN AN AGGRESSIVE
CANDIDATE IN RON DESANT, BUT HE
IS DISAPPOINTING A LOT OF THOSE
REPUBLICANS BECAUSE HE'S ON
STAGE WITH ALL OF THESE ELECTION
DENIERS SUPPORTING THEM AS MUCH
AS HE CAN, KARI LAKE AND DOUG
MASTRIANO IN PENNSYLVANIA, DOING
AN EVENT WITH HIM TOO AS WELL.
>> IT IS THE TRUMP PARTY,
WHETHER YOU HAVE TRUMP OR NOT,
THEY'RE ALL IMITATING HIM, IT'S
THE LESSON THEY LEARNED FROM
HIM.
YOU DON'T NEED TO APPEAL TO THE
MIDDLE ANYMORE.
IF YOU TURN OUT BASE
REPUBLICANS, PLAY TO THE BASE
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY, THERE'S A
PATH TO VICTORY.
THAT'S VERY SHORT SIGHTED, NOT A
GOOD LONG TERM PLAY, BUT WHAT
EVERY REPUBLICAN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IS TRYING TO EMULATE.
NOW, IS THERE A PATH FOR A LIZ
CHENEY TO BROADEN US BACK OUT TO
A TRADITIONAL CONSERVATIVE
PARTY?
I HOPE SO, BUT I DON'T KNOW.
I REALLY DOUBT IT.
>> IS THERE EVEN A PATH AT THIS
POINT FOR RON DeSANTIS IF DONALD
TRUMP RUNS?
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THE MORNING
CONSULT POLL THAT SHOWS NOW 58%
OF REPUBLICAN VOTERS SAY THEY
WOULD BACK TRUMP, THIS IS AFTER
THE FBI SEARCH.
>> HIS NUMBERS WENT UP.
>> HIS NUMBERS ACTUALLY WENT UP,
AND TRUMP WORLD SAYS WE'RE
CONSOLIDATING SUPPORT.
IT WENT UP AT THE SUPPORT OF RON
DeSANTIS WHO WENT DOWN BY 5% IN
THAT POLL.
REPUBLICAN STRATEGISTS ARE
SAYING THEY SEE THE PATHWAY
NARROWING FOR RON DeSANTIS OR
ANYBODY ESAFTER THAT.
>> DO YOU SEE THE DEMOCRATS
MEETING THIS MOMEINT TERMS OF
THEIR TRYING TO APPEAL TO THESE
VOTERS IN THE MIDDLE, TO TRY TO
APPEAL TO DISILLUSIONED
REPUBLICANS SUCH AS MY FRIEND
HERE TO MY RIGHT?
OR DO YOU THINK DEMOCRATS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THAT?
>> I THINK THEY HAVE TO DO A
BETTER JOB.
YOU PROBABLY SAW THERE WAS A
MOMY THAT CAME OUT FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO GO ON A MESSAGING TOUR.
THEY HAVE TO TALK TO THE ENTIRE
BASE, NOT JUST BLACK AND BROWN
VOTERS, WHICH THEY NEED TO
EXCITE, AND THEY NEED TO TURB
OUT BECAUSE THEY WILL NOT WIN IF
PEOPLE MY AGE AND YOUNGER AND OF
COLOR VOTERS STAY HOME.
THAT IS VERY CLEAR.
BUT THEY ALSO HAVE PLATFORMS OR
POLICIES THAT THEY CAN GO TO
TALK TO SUBURBAN WHITE MOMS, TO
TALK TO THE RURAL FARMER, AND
NOT JUST SAY THAT WE'RE DOING
SOMETHING FOR YOU, BUT IF YOU
PICK SOMEBODY ELSE, THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO DO ANYTHING FOR YOU.
WE'RE TRYING AND WE NEED TO
EXPAND OUR MARGINS.
I DON'T THINK THAT THEY HAVE
LANDED THE PLANE JUST YET ON THE
MESSAGING, BUT THEY DO STILL
HAVE SOME TIME.
>> DO YOU AGREE?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THE
CHALLENGE FOR DEMOCRATS HERE,
ONE OF THE THINGS I THINK IS ON
THE FLIP SIDE OF WHAT'S HAPPENED
OVER THE PAST WEEK IN TERMS OF
TRUMP, IT'S PUT TRUMP FRONT AND
CENTER AGAIN.
MIDTERMS, THAT'S GOOD FOR
DEMOCRATS NO MATTER WHICH WAY
YOU SLICE IT.
>> YOU THINK?
>> I THINK CERTAINLY DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGISTS I TALK TO WOULD LOVE
FOR THE MIDTERMS TO BE ABOUT
TRUMP, AND NOW THEY ALSO HAVE A
BUNCH OF POLICIES THEY CAN ALSO
SELL ON TOP OF IT.
THEY'RE IN A MUCH STRONGER
POSITION.
>> REFERENDUMS ON THE PRESIDENT.
FOR ONCE, IT'S GOING TO BE A BIT
OF A CHOICE.
YOU HAVE BETWEEN THE JANUARY 6th
HEARINGS REMINDING PEOPLE OF
WHAT DONALD TRUMP DID, YOU HAVE
CANDIDATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHO ARE CRAZY, AND REMINDING
PEOPLE THAT REPUBLICANS ARE NOT
THE SAME PARTY THEY USED TO BE,
SO I THINK THAT'S WHERE
DEMOCRATS HAVE A CHANCE.
YOU HAVE A CHOICE SELECTION,
WHICH IS WHAT PEOPLE TRY TO HAVE
IN MIDTERMS.
>> YOU THROW ABORTION IN THERE,
AND IT LIGHTS THE BASE UP MORE.
>> WE'LL SEE.